el principal desafío para la prensa será
precisamente a nivel local y regional
poder cubrir lo que está sucediendo en
los lugares donde en la intensificación
del conflicto ha aumentado hoy como
mencionaba en departamentos como cauca
putumayo arauca choco pues va a ser muy
difícil saber tener las garantías para
que los periodistas puedan cubrir lo que
está sucediendo
sobre todo en las semanas previas a las
elecciones por otro lado también están
los desafíos de los entornos digitales
que es cada vez un espacio más hostil y
agresivo contra los periodistas donde es
importante exigir a los movimientos
políticos que por supuesto den las
garantías y el compromiso de no
contratar campañas de desinformación ni
campañas de desprestigio dirigidas los
medios de comunicación ni a los
periodistas